all right David
hi there David where'd you grow up where
are you from originally uh I'm from a
place called Petaluma California and
that's up in the Bay area up North tell
me about your family growing up
growing up my family I'm a first
generation my family grew up in Mexico
so both my father and my mother grew up
in Mexico
um and um I'm the first generation that
was born here in America you know they
crossed over for a better life for us
and for a better opportunity
how would you describe your your
childhood I would describe it
um very very rough it I faced a lot of
adversity growing up uh basically ever
since I was five single parent uh no
father father was out of the picture uh
I had to endure a lot of
um poverty I was on welfare food stamps
I remember not having enough food for
everybody all the time when I was a
child I uh I was often late to school
because I had to wait for my mother to
get off finishing her first out of three
jobs uh crossing guard so that she could
take me to school safely until a point
where she could no longer afford to do
that physically she had to stay at her
job extra so I could have I couldn't
have any support going to school I had
to walk myself there
um that amounted to
Progressive alcoholism uh my I'm the
youngest of five and my brother because
my my father left and his mental health
issues he I had a lot of bipolar and
schizophrenic issues and when he was 16
17 a lot of uh you know symptoms so he
started taking medication and then
drinking on top of it and because of
that he is now permanently schizophrenic
and he would take out his rage and anger
and frustration of not having friends
not having enough food
um on his own family he would physically
abuse and you know like basically beat
the crap out of my mom and my three
sisters uh right in front of my eyes and
there was nothing I can do except feel
so helpless and uh and just watch if you
do as well he never abused me for
whatever reason for some reason he
looked to me for support and convert
after the acts of physical abuse you
know kind of like as like consolation
and I I never felt comfortable ever
giving it to him after witnessing what
he did so um that's what it was like
almost on you know a weekly basis
um like holes and holes in almost every
door in the house and walls and my mom
did the best she could do she did three
jobs and um I had to go with her on the
third job that she would go to which was
cleaning offices at like eight or nine
PM after her second job because she
couldn't afford a babysitter while she
was out so she would bring me the
youngest of five while everyone else is
put in bed to go clean until it was time
to go home and go to bed and I would do
that up until I could start legally
working at 16 or 16 and a half I think
that was the legal age in California so
that I can support my mother and myself
financially
and things slowly started getting better
after that
um but that's how it was growing up you
know I was the kid that never really had
any presence under the Christmas tree
um
you know the kid that uh basically just
I try to fit in but could never fit in
you know just wanted comfort and friends
and food and you finish High School yeah
I did graduate high school with the
diploma I attended some college as well
good
what did you want to do with your life
um I think I still want to do it I was
pursuing a career in radiography for a
radiologic technologist
so essentially you're just taking x-rays
for patients whether it's in a clinic or
a hospital
[Music]
um
you know wherever you can take an image
of like a radiograph is what it's called
and I was pursuing that for about a year
and a half two years and finished all
the prerequisites I stopped doing that
when I started needing to go back to
work so I can sustain myself because my
mother said that she would no longer
sustain uh me being in her house I was
about 21 or 22 at the time and she
thought that it was about time for me to
start working for my living and so I
stopped going to school that's when I
got into car sales and that's when my
alcoholism my own alcoholism
progressively started there was a bar
next door to the garage and the sale of
the dealership of the Subaru I was
working at and I'd go there for drinks
with co-workers after work slowly
progressively during lunch every day
um and I lost that job due to a DUI
um and from there it's kind of been
downhill life's never really gotten any
better for me because I chose to pursue
a career in drugs and alcohol instead of
trying to better my life
um and that's when I started
experimenting with drugs especially
opiates
um opiates I I've tried you know uppers
and cocaine and and all that other stuff
but because my life growing up it's just
I was full of anxiety my whole entire
childhood that it would give me nothing
but anxiety doing those kinds of drugs I
needed something to kind of chill me out
and calm me down so that's where I found
alcohol for my solution and marijuana
for my solution to kind of just take the
edge off so I could feel like I could
breathe again you know and
um so that's what opiates did for me as
well and Xanax that's why I love the
downers I'm a total Downer dude total
Downer dude and um
that took me to do a lot of Geographics
I used to move around different areas
and
um my problems follow me wherever I go
and nothing ever got better wherever I
went
you say no so now I stay actually
um it's kind of small yeah well it's
it's
um I was uh going to the mission but
they didn't have any room available no
beds so I ended up finding a small
little studio apartment for aspiring
artists musicians and basically people
that are trying to improve and better
their lives I found in a small little
apartment unit and that's actually a
very close by
and how do you support yourself
um I work I find right now side jobs
right now currently I am
um
thankfully healthy enough I'm not you
know to get up in the morning and get
myself out of bed and you know hit
somewhere where there's Wi-Fi to go look
for jobs I have I apply to five to ten
jobs a day I've been doing this for
about two to three months and it's just
been unfortunately slow because of the
holiday season you know a lot of
companies aren't really working or
looking for employees around this time
of the year
um I've I've had a job ever since I've
been in Los Angeles and
um it's in the restaurant industry and
because I decided to start showing up
um high on fentanyl
um eventually they started catching on
so of course they took away my hours
they were getting away huh that'll get
in the way yes yes of course and I don't
know what I was thinking and why I
thought that was a good idea but that's
just where my brain my attic brain will
take me to those places for for some
reason it just seems like a good idea or
like why not No One's Gonna know no
one's ever going to find out of course
they do and they did right so I got cut
off from work since November and I've
been looking for side jobs
to support myself financially to pay for
my rent and um you know to do my best to
stay off Fentanyl
how are you doing with that
um it's
it's an upward slope kind of like a
stock stock market graph you know up and
down up and down but the overall trend
is going up it's going good I'm not
going to say it's going great
um because you know I have had a couple
of overdoses uh you know within the last
like month or two
um and those would be about my eighth or
my ninth overdose on fentanyl the last
one that I had
um that was
um that was my wake-up call because that
was the first time where I actually uh
died for uh about half an hour
um if no one was there resuscitating me
with CPR and so paramedics arrived
paramedics told the person resuscitating
me that I would have not made it um my
heart rate was next to five beats per
minute they said and uh they gave me
three or four shots of Narcan just to
wake me up and get me out of the Slumber
and I don't remember ever waking up like
that or how I got in that position or
place but all I remember is just kind of
like curtains of Blackness or Darkness
but the other way like when people start
blacking out you know their Vision
starts going black from the front I
started waking up and I started getting
my vision from the back forward but I
was in a Stretcher all of a sudden and I
had an ambulance like calling me by my
name and I had no idea what had happened
and then I realized it's because I
snorted
um way too much way too much and that
was very recently that was about two and
a half to three weeks ago
that was my wake-up call that's when I
decided that I really wanted a change
for my life for my future because if I
don't do it I'm either gonna die or in
my opinion what's worse is live a life
full of suffering which is you know what
we see out here and I I can't do that to
myself anymore I can't do that to my mom
I can't do that to my family you know
she sacrificed so much for me dude and
and that's that's what I'm and that's
how I'm I'm gonna treat her sacrifices
that she made so I can live a better
life I can't do that that's selfish
um you know I've I've been in in and out
of uh Alcoholics Anonymous Narcotics
Anonymous I've been working programs
that's what got me into the position I'm
at where I'm able to stand on my own two
feet with a roof over my head my problem
has been just keeping what I have earned
and staying off the fentanyl I always
for some reason stop
remembering how bad it got and I just
think that my mind will go to places
crazy places where all of a sudden it
just thinks it's a great idea to go get
a little sack and go get high real quick
and next thing I know I'm blacking out
and I've lost my backpack I've lost my
clothes I've last lost my laptop in fact
that happened
um
right before the two week two weeks ago
that happened about four or five days
before that overdose I overdosed and I
woke up my phone was gone my wallet was
Gone with eighty dollars I had my ID in
there you know and and now I'm going
through employment issues my ID because
I'm waiting for an ID now I can't get a
job all of these problems keep adding up
and it gets only worse and worse all
because I think that smoking fentanyl is
a good idea and obviously it's not and I
really need to just completely get off
it like entirely I take you know I I've
had almost 10 overdoses and I've died
are you still drinking as well I drink
um
uh not frequently
um I would I wouldn't say in between
moderately and and very occasionally
I'll have probably three or four drinks
a week
um I mean I guess five or six because I
drink tall cans I don't drink like you
know the little ones or whatever
um and you know I do I do smoke
marijuana I smoke weed
um you know I smoke weed every night I
stay off the weed and and the booze uh
stay off it all day so I can you know go
go to Starbucks go get my coffee somehow
or somewhere and pull out the laptop
with somewhere with internet where I can
hopefully look for a job and take care
of my business and then at the end of
the night after I feel like I did you
know a good enough job or effort into a
better a better life for myself then
maybe you know I'll have like a tall can
or two and and I'll smoke my weed I do
smoke weed
um I am trying to stop smoking weed uh
eventually again because and drink too
because
um I have my longest length of sobriety
straight sobriety no alcohol no nothing
was about three or four months and that
was the best sleep I've ever gotten in
my life
um and so I'm trying to get back to that
point but for right now I'm doing what I
what I feel like I need to do to stay as
far away from fentanyl as possible
because that's what's going to kill me
or
even worse is just live a life full of
insanity
do you have any friends
I do
um if I mean
very few I've burned all those bridges
I've burned I've burned a lot of
relationships in my past
obviously from stealing from family or
friends so I can get high
and you know just just overall
relationship issues and just trust
issues
um I've lost most of them you know say I
barely have even family that barely
wants to talk to me or they don't even
take my word for what I say because how
can they have I've betrayed their trust
and and I've lied to them for years and
years almost you know eight nine years
up to this point when my my addiction
started and
um it's so hard to gain that trust back
that you know I don't have essentially
anyone out here I don't have a community
out here I don't have any friends out
here I'm really out here by myself
how old are you I just turned 30 years
old on New Year's Eve they're at the
31st
um so uh yeah
happy birthday thank you thank you I
appreciate it it felt good uh not
getting high on my birthday
um for the first time and in a long time
and I feel comfortable I'm proud to say
that you know
um it's hard it's not easy you know
every day is a little harder
um then or some days harder than others
some days easier than others to want to
get high but getting the the getting
high aspect the the obsession in my mind
um it's something that doesn't go away
permanently it might go away for a week
two weeks or a month but eventually even
it's for for a second or a day that
thought will come into my own head and
be like hey you know remember when you
used to smoke you know dope or remember
when you're smoking dope you know you
want to go get high real quick and um I
just got to make sure you know like
every day I keep my myself in check into
focusing on what I need to do to stay
away from smoking fentanyl because just
one bad stressful event I can just say
[__] it and I'm gonna go get a sack I
know where to go you can find that [__]
anywhere around here and it's killing
everybody left and right but for some
reason that statement and that
understanding alone is still not enough
for me to push me away for some reason
me knowing that I might lose everything
I have again I might die that most of
the time it keeps me away from copying
but sometimes there's nothing that's
going to keep me from going to get high
and those are the days where you know I
really need to figure out how I can
avoid getting AI because every time that
happens I'll go get high I'll go get a
case of the [__] hits if I didn't get
the job if something doesn't go right
this this and that boom boom boom if
things don't go my way
and I'm not in a good mood already it's
a lot easier for me to go and just say
[__] yeah I'm gonna just go get a sack I
know where to go real quick
and at that point once once my mind's
made up the action is gonna follow you
know is that an addiction issue or is it
a self-worth issue
I would say it's two sides of the same
coin because I feel like you know uh my
value as a person I feel like I have
some value but I just don't know to what
extent and I haven't discovered what I'm
worth you know and every day I wake up
and and I'm not like I grew up
religiously like staunch Catholic
household church every Sunday and I mean
I'm not like a church goer some
sometimes I'll come around a church but
I'm more spiritual and I believe in God
obviously you know and I talked to God I
talk to God every single day and I ask
him for guidance and strength and
direction and just show me what I need
to do in order for me to live the right
life that
that you want me to live like give me
your purpose show me the purpose that
please like because without that I'm I
don't if without that purpose that God
wants
to give me I'm I'm gonna go out there
and get high again I'm get I'm just
gonna go out there and use you know
it's just gonna happen
and um
God God works God for me personally is
very real my power very real because
there's just been so many things
happening in the past two or three weeks
that have been nothing but just Miracles
or God shots just just nothing but short
of that and
I got dropped off at the mission and
they had no more room for me in the
morning this was before I got this place
and so when I left the mission I looked
around at all of the stuff that was
around me at skid row and all the people
and literal human [__] on the ground
that you got to watch out and not step
on and all of these things and just
trash everywhere and I had all my
luggage and I'm thinking to myself and
I'm saying out loud God do I really want
to live like this anymore
and so for about a half an hour I I
prayed out loud to to my higher power of
my understanding and I said I just give
me strength and direction because I
don't want to live like this no more I
want to change
and I ended up at a market that's you
know uh fairly close by to you know uh
uh skid row and right next door to the
market is a um a monthly Hotel Apartment
Complex
um for like subsidized housing and I
called the number they said they had a
room and long story short even though I
had like no money up front to pay for
the initial first month and last month
of rent I made a deal with the landlord
and explained my story and my situation
and he he said he could hear in my voice
that I was being truthful and honest but
if I we couldn't make a deal then I
would have to uh leave essentially we
made a deal I can pay you 25 percent of
the rent within the next two or three
days because that's all I can get and
um you know I'll continue I'll
continuously pay you money every week so
that I can maintain a roof over my head
I just want a chance to live a better
life
and I don't want to live like this
anymore and he said okay so we made the
deal and I paid him those 100 and ever
since then that day I've had a roof over
my head with restrooms uh with you know
a shower and a laundry
um you know I still struggle a little
bit with you know uh uh getting high I
got high actually you know a little bit
earlier today
um you know and um but uh I'm working on
you know making sure I keep that in
check and I'm doing the best I can do to
just completely stop smoking fentanyl
because it's gonna kill me or it's gonna
ruin me there's no other choice or
there's no other solution or option
what emotions do you go through living
this life
just like straight to spare
uh
hopelessness
uh Agony and pain
uh loneliness
uh emptiness
um
mistrust in the world and and society
and all of that is so alienating that it
makes me want to stay away from people
instead of socialize and connect with
other people we're social beings you
know and
all those kinds of things like living
that kind of life and the daily stress
of not being able to find a job and not
having a phone to look for work not
having all of that stuff it's so
amounting that I'd some days I just
rather not wake up I'd rather not be
alive
but um that's when I ask for strength
and guidance and for some for some
reason I that's what I receive and I get
out of bed and um
there's something planned or lined up
for me when when I ask for that guidance
um
I don't know what the day is going to
bring
but I just have the faith and the trust
that whatever it brings hopefully I'll
be ready for it so that I can uh
just be one percent better or even half
a percent better than I was yesterday
you know and um just small little
improvements I [__] my life up for
eight years nine years
my parents
my mom you know my dad who the [__]
knows I don't know
my sisters and um
yeah we've been friends that that I've
burned and
it's it's not going to fix overnight and
I wanted to I wanted to fix itself
overnight but it's it's not reality I I
burned everything down for eight to nine
years so the least I can assume is it's
going to take just as long for me to
build everything that I've burned down
back up
and um I'm really trying to be patient
with myself
um even though I want to fix my life
today and right now I know it's just not
reality so I just got to make sure that
I stay away from dope and stop smoking
fentanyl because I know for a fact that
as soon as I start doing that I will
lose a job again I'll lose a roof over
my head again
and I'll end up on the street in Skid
Row again
I'll lose everything and everyone the
few people I have left if you could have
any one wish what would that wish be
I wish I can go back in time
I wish I could go back in time and uh
foreign
thank you
I wish I could go back in time and uh
not just erase all the wrongs I've done
to my family
but fix them
I have so many events to make today
I could write a book
and all of the pain
that I went through is probably nothing
compared to the pain that I put my
family through
and there's nothing I can do to go back
and fix that
but I can certainly start today
foreign my best
have you been in love before
I have yeah yeah I was a
high school sweetheart uh dated here for
five and a half years six years
and uh
from Brazil and
things got sour because I was being
selfish
instead of being with her I wanted to go
smoke weed with my friends my high
school friends
and um you know before she got fed up
with it after a couple years
and you know things just ended and you
know
I haven't really spoke much to her wish
I could make things right with her and
make make amends and
and fix that because you know that was
my first love and
I haven't really felt any love like that
since so
foreign
that my biggest fear is that my mom is
going to die
before she gets to see me live the life
that she
would like me to live
do you think people don't understand
about drug addiction
uh
it's something that must be experienced
to fully or truly understand
and um in order to experience drug
addiction you know one must try or you
know use drugs
I feel like you know I feel like it is
it is it is Agent a genetic disease but
I also do feel like there are drugs out
there in our society especially you know
pharmacology
um or excuse me Pharmaceutical
you know like someone that's never done
drugs in their life if you if they break
a bone or like an NFL player or an
athlete you know and then they get
prescribed say Oxycontin for you know
about three months and you gotta take
one every day and and then that's all
they got well after the three-month
Supply is gone and then they're cut off
they can't get any more Oxycontin
they're gonna get withdrawals you know
um that's a form it's that's addiction
right there where your body is going
through a physical withdrawal because
um it now has become Reliant and
dependent on the substance that it is no
longer being provided so now it has to
come up and make and produce its own
chemicals
um
I think what people don't really
understand about addiction is is like I
said is that um it's a lot easier to
thinking you understand it rather than
to truly understand it because to truly
understand it you have to experience
what it's like to use drugs and and then
feel like wow like this is what it's
like to be high now I don't not want to
be high you know if this is if I can get
this much dopamine or Euphoria from just
five seconds of smoking something off a
piece of tin foil what's the point of
you know doing anything else if I can
just feel this good for 5 10 15 20
dollars
um and it's also too like the the
obsession you know people with addiction
they mentally obsess over these things
the drugs they think about them often
the thoughts come into their head
um and that's all they want to do
because that's all their their mind can
think about
it's like it's like alcoholism where if
someone that's an alcoholic that doesn't
have any they're going through
withdrawals things like that they go to
a store a grocery store and they walk
past the liquor store the liquor aisle
or the beer aisle you know they're going
to be staring at you know the bottles
and the beer for a long time wishing
that they could have a drink
um you know it's the same type of thing
whereas it's just constantly on your
mind just whatever the addiction is
whether it's you know
uh compulsive eating
um you know people have like like eating
and diet issues or
um it's more of a broad spectrum Under
the Umbrella of Mental Health and I feel
like as a society we we need we need to
be uh uh really paying a lot more
attention towards mental health uh
because I feel like Addiction in general
uh comes from mental health uh you know
uh issues
what would you say is the most important
lesson you've learned in your life
um
the opportunity is there but I have to
and the door is open but I have to
choose to walk through that door
I have a choice and I have the freedom
to make that choice whether that's what
my higher power gave me or whether
that's just the way our society works I
that that's not what's important and
that's not for me to understand what I
need to understand is
faith without works is dead so I I can
really believe in God or higher power or
believe that you know I have a chance at
creating a life of myself that is a
normal life you know like a normal
person in society that contributes but I
have to put the work and I have to
choose to walk through that door if I
just stare at the door that's open and I
don't take any action I'll never have
that life I have I have to believe but I
also have to take action
all right David thank you so much for
sharing your story
thank you wish you all the luck in the
world thank you thank you man